Esther how about this the idea of the
submissive
female I mean sometimes I want to be
submissive I do it on purpose like
sometimes I'm a switch I don't think
anything wrong of that do you understand
the stereotype mhm like you're supposed
to like do everything that a man tells
you to do right yeah but like it's
mostly Asian sometimes it's hot
sometimes it's hot I like her but that's
sometimes they're thinking all the time
more like it being a stereotype that
every woman should every Asian woman is
like that that's why white men have like
yellow fever is I don't even look at
white men so a
queen okay emasculated male I think you
me Point At You Out of there's like
eight people here you were looking at me
I think it's cuz me and I giving a
microphone Holding On Me P for being B
yeah I'm pretty emasculated yeah that's
the small dick thing you were talking
about though is it yeah get rid of that
one you can live with that one I'm
already married Bro she's locked in dude
she already knows how small that is
bro